[Musik]
ob zeit in einem krankenhaus in haag
marina und sergej seien ärzte und seit
15 jahren ein paar sie behandeln
krebskranke menschen wie die meisten
ihre hochzeitsgäste
oksana ist radiologin die 44-jährige ist
marinas trauzeugen innerhalb von zwei
tagen hat sie die hochzeit organisiert
einfach mal glücklich sein feiern
mitten im krieg
bomben bei der segnung so sieht hochzeit
heute in kharkiv aus
trotz der explosionen sind oxana und ihr
team kurz nach der hochzeit wieder in
der stadt im einsatz am nächsten tag
sind wir zu einem videotelefonat
verabredet doch oksana ist nicht online
stunden lang gibt es kein lebenszeichen
von ihr die angriffe russischer
streitkräfte auf ukrainische städte
haben in den vergangenen tagen stark
zugenommen auch in relativ spät abends
endlich eine nachricht von oxana
heute haben sie uns heftig angegriffen
es sind noch nicht alle von uns zurück
falls sie heute überhaupt wieder kommen
oksana und ihre kollegen haben überlebt
und sind unversehrt
[Musik]
heute ist es hier ein haarschnitt sehr
schlimm ich unser stadtzentrum wurde den
ganzen tag
wir wurden
das ändere aber nichts daran dass ihre
patientin sie dringend brauchen vor
allem die schwer kranken
ich bin doch erste und meine patienten
sind hier und
den patienten geht es sehr schlecht vor
allem denen die wir nicht mehr gut genug
behandeln können ohne medikamente
breitet sich der krebs aus um zu sterben
wahrscheinlich darin
[Musik]
deswegen machen sie auch hausbesuche
bringen medikamente vorbei die meisten
patienten sind ein prostata oder
brustkrebs erkrankt 30 werden stationär
behandelt
auch wenn die stadt bombardiert dass
explosionen gibt wir angst haben oder es
gefährlich wird wir bleiben bei den
patienten
die ärzte tun was sie können doch
medikamente werden knapp operationen
sind nicht mehr möglich
unser op saal ist im dritten stock
wenn es luftangriffe während der op gibt
wird es extrem gefährlich für die
patienten
die wären alle tod
aktiv zu verlassen war und ist keine
option sie bleiben und kämpfen für ihre
patienten so lange sie können
und schaffen sich in all dem leid
unvergessliche momente
als wir fürs shooting draußen waren
haben die menschen angefangen zu lächeln
und fragten mach dir das wirklich
[Musik]
bis der nächste bombenangriff kommt
wir sind gerade wieder bombardiert
worden
es macht einem angst aber es ist so man
gewöhnt sich daran es ist wie es ist es
ist wie es ist
das ist dennis aus einem etwa 500
kilometer entfernten dorf bike ihr vater
diese videos geschickt auf diesen moment
hatte den ganzen tag gewartet ein auto
voll mit hilfslieferungen hat es in
seinem dorf geschafft
sie sind ca ja hallo hallo hier ist das
auto bis zum geht nicht mehr voll
komplett voll bis zum dach
die freiwilligen helfer haben die
spenden aus lemberg im westen der
ukraine gebracht
wir sammeln ganz verschiedene dinge für
bedürftige menschen es gibt einige
mütter frauen die hilfe brauchen es gibt
ganz verschiedene bedürfnisse sie
brauchen windeln verschiedene
hygieneprodukte wir suchen selbst
unterwäsche
in diesen tagen ist die
hilfsbereitschaft groß
einer der bewohner hier hat uns frische
milch gebracht das ist so nett in
kriegszeiten jetzt fangen jetzt das ist
lustig jemand hat um sein buch geschickt
auf dänisch wir können kein technischer
bei vielen dank verein unserer
freiwilligen hat gerade angerufen und
gesagt dass sie neue medikamente bringt
doch die ukrainische bürger wer hier
spürt der kreis der russischen panzer
zieht sich immer enger um kiew und
dennis dorf er und sein team
unterstützen deshalb auch die dorf
verteidigung
denn es hat eine spendenkampagne
gestartet für einen pickup truck damit
könnten die reservisten und freiwilligen
streitkräfte seinem dorf besser
verteidigen
hoffentlich können wir die nächsten
beiden tagen dieses auto kaufen ehrlich
gesagt habe ich noch nie in meinem leben
ein auto gekauft ich konnte mir nie
vorstellen dass ich jemals ein auto
kaufen würde besonders keinen diesel wie
sie ihn wollen denn ich bin
umweltschützer
13.000 us dollar haben sie am ersten tag
schon gesammelt doch es gibt nur noch
wenige solcher trucks im land noch ist
denn es unsicher ob sie den richtigen
auftreiben können während die
spendenaktion weiterläuft treffen sie
vorbereitungen für eine mögliche
belagerten kws denn die angreifer rücken
immer näher die attacken werden heftiger
dennis und die helfenden legen vorräte
an
wir fangen jetzt an verschiedene
haltbare lebensmittel zu besorgen falls
das schwere bombenangriffe in unseren
gebieten gibt und wir lange zeit im
keller bleiben müssen viele haben kiew
und das umland schon verlassen sind in
den westen geflohen so auch dennis
nachbar
unsere nachbarin hat gesagt wir können
ein paar lebensmittel aus ihrem keller
holen sie haben sich für ein paar tage
hier drin versteckt bevor sie das dorf
verlassen haben wir holen ein paar
kartoffeln von dem werk wird in sumter
des 15 zwei tage später gibt es
neuigkeiten bei der suche nach einem
pickup-truck 15.000 us dollar haben
dennis und die helfer innerhalb von drei
tagen gesammelt damit könnten sie jetzt
dieses auto für die soldaten kaufen talk
der wagen etwas die jungs schauen den
jetzt an und überprüfen ob alles okay
ist die soldaten sehen sich den wagen
genau an
und sind zufrieden denn es kauft den
trank
hoffentlich hilft uns dieser truck mehr
leute in der ukraine zu schützen die
russische invasion und putin sehr sehr
bald zu stoppen
habt eine gute nacht
dennis und weitere hundert menschen
waren auch diese nacht im keller einer
schule aus und hoffen auf ein ende des
krieges
diese hoffnung teilt auch mal aus der
ukraine ist chirurg in einem krankenhaus
nahe des kriegs gebietes unter seinen
patienten sind auch verwundete soldaten
viel zeigen darf er nicht sein richtiger
name und sein aufenthaltsort müssen
geheim bleiben die meisten verletzungen
sinkt die schusswunden das kann auch
extremitäten
[Musik]
alle alle
regionen sind betroffen der 31-jährige
wollte schon immer arzt werden sein ziel
als chirurg in deutschland arbeiten im
jahr 2009 10 ist ja für einige monate
hier lernt die sprache und macht eine
weiterbildung auch als russland ende
februar die ukraine angreift ist der
gerade in deutschland auf stellensuche
es war glaube ich in deutschland bin ich
sofort zurück gefahren und es hat
während gefährt zwei tage gekostet bis
sich alle grenzen alle länder ich konnte
nicht fliegen mahlers bleibt nur ein
kleiner rucksack er kann nicht mehr nach
hause seine heimatstadt in der süd
ukraine steht unter dauerbeschuss ich
wollte nur eine chirurgische stelle in
den runden möglichst schnell
einzuarbeiten
für seinen einsatz zahlt er einen hohen
preis er muss sich von seiner frau und
seiner fünfjährigen tochter trennen
meine frau ist auch ärzten deswegen sie
macht auch ihre arbeit aber in einem
anderen krankenhaus sind in zwei
verschiedenen städten
und meine tochter ist bei meiner großen
bei meiner mutter sowie bei ihrer
großmutter und die datensicherheit
mahlers leben spielt sich nur noch im
krankenhaus ab privatsphäre gibt es kaum
zu fünft schlafen sie in einem kleinen
zimmer
solange der krieg andauert wird er seine
frau und tochter nicht sehen können zu
weit weg zu gefährlich die verteidigung
seiner heimat gegenüber putins russland
sehr wichtiger als alles andere
es wird von einem menschen ab und keiner
weiß was in seinem kopf ist die wir nie
aufgeben die aufschreiben und wir werden
bis zum ende kämpfen bis zum letzten
soldaten bis zum letzten menschen der
bereit ist
unseres land zu schützen
viermal aus steht fest der krieg ist
sinnlos russische soldaten bringen ohne
rücksicht menschen um die zerstörte noch
alles
dann es eine lebenserhaltende aktion und
eine wahnsinn ich habe keine angst von
gängen wer keinen ganz ich habe lukas
trotz seines hasses hat mal es noch
hoffnung auf frieden und er hat räume
für eine zeit nach dem krieg ich werde
mit meiner familie einen schönen urlaub
machen und dann ich habe immer noch mal
vor in deutschland als arzt habe das
wird in der zukunft sein
jetzt haben wir eine andere aufgabe